this is the gateway drug it is i mean
this is it so be careful what if i told
you this watch is around 300 bucks it
can't be you know you instead of going
out for dinner buy a watch
okay mr wonderful here you know i'm
doing a very special edition for the
channel today because people ask me all
the time about my collection my watches
and some of them are crazy expensive
pieces but i buy them as an investor so
i'm okay with that it's an asset class
for me but what about watches that you
can approach in terms of a price point
that makes sense and i also have watches
like that so i asked my great buddy
teddy over here he's a legend he really
knows how to root out he's like a
truffle pig on watches he knows how to
go find them great dials
beautiful pieces at affordable prices so
i asked him to bring his very best to
walk us together through what you could
look at today
that's affordable it's beautiful almost
collectible in the sense that they're
different from each other and look
spectacular on your wrist or your wife
so your significant others you got to
think about gifting too let's go at it
teddy what do you got here for me so in
terms of love to set the record straight
some of these are not what i would
classify as affordable but in terms of
what is affordable to you it's all it's
all relative right i mean
these are probably these are affordable
for you but i mean there's going to be
some people out there where these are
you know still some very aspirational
pieces that are cool so i just want to
provide that context but okay all of
these for i would say but we should
discuss price point right we should
discuss price point all these are going
to be sub 10 000
okay so i agree that's not cheap
um when i'm talking about really
affordable like sort of a 1200 down kind
of thing we do have some of those as
well okay and i guess we could start
with those now let's start with those
we'll start with the ones that some of
these are i would say if at least i get
the question all the time i need my
first quality watch yeah where should i
go okay so let's talk about that from
this let's choose the first quality
watch somebody should should or could
get i'm gonna pick two okay then i'm
also gonna mention a third just as like
a kind of a little bit more out there
but a kind of a cult classic
so
these two right here you're probably
familiar with both these brands tiso
in hamilton one of my very first gifts
was a tiso
a classic swiss tiso it's the this is
the gateway drug this is the gateway
drug it is i mean this is it so be
careful do not
get too involved with this if you just
know what you're getting into that's all
i'm saying so this is the new prx yeah
clearly we see some inspiration it's got
a little bit of like some rolex oyster
quartz kind of dna this is a model that
was kind of recreated from one of their
like from their archive uh from the
right what are we talking about price
teddy
650 there's also a quartz version as
well for even less than that sub 400. so
it's just a great watch the bracelet
finishing we'll get some close-ups of
this and just show that but this is hot
is a fantastic entry level price and a
beautiful piece that has even some of
the
rolex explorer elements to it you know
with the best thing you can see with the
bezel as well you know it's got that i
would say like oyster quartz kind of dna
with this case silhouette but but
certainly you could mistake this for a
rolex lacrosse ap you could you know it
looks the part for 650 bucks and also
this amazing this interesting dial
texture with the bluish kind of spotting
it's very very good that is a great find
okay that one's doing incredibly well so
the other watch that i have here and if
you're talking about entry-level swiss
watch 500 bucks yeah i just say
look at hamilton just look at hamilton i
hamilton brand in the last two years all
of a sudden it's like it's woken up
it's got it's got a real buzz going on
it for sort of a hot watch at a great
price what's the price point 500 575
bucks for this retail and
this is the thing that i like about also
right on trend with a smaller dial
it's 38 millimeters
very wearable 100 meters of water
resistance that is your that's your one
and only watch that's why i love that
watch i mean the t so is a little bit
more sporty that's right on that fence
automatically
you can wear with jeans you could wear
with a suit i mean it would work
and you could put a red band on this
you could that's not where i was going
with it but you certainly could it's got
a little sparkle of red on there that
you could call your accoutrement right
on the second hand the tip is red that's
very very nice hamilton has the history
they have lineage quite a quality on the
wine you feel that beautiful grind
they have some of the best movements in
the price range so these i mean there
are swatch group brands so you have some
perks with that 80 hour power reserves
so far what you showed me this is my top
pick it's really nice for an entry level
that's a great point and there's so many
different it's a little overwhelming the
amount of khakis that you have at your
disposal but that's fantastic so we have
that one let's look at some other things
so actually i want to
diverge and look at something a little
bit different now this is a micro brand
now why i wanted to show you this though
so this is a brand based out of scotland
it's called anordaine now what they are
known for
is their dials and because they don't
make their own caliber movement right no
okay and that's why these are under two
thousand dollars right but
this dial is handmade enamel and in
terms of enameling of this quality at
this price range
i have yet to find something and these
seem like really good down-to-earth guys
they're true artisans this is called
their plum dial and i liked it because
it did have a little bit of some red to
it and it was a bit different but if you
get close to it you see that texture
texture look at that texture
wow these guys can't seem it's crazy
because the amount of time they put into
the the watch dials themselves is
spectacular they're just sold out of
these all the time so it's hard to get
production on these price points 102
grand
pretty cool though right i mean for that
dial it's very unique you would not see
anybody else with this watch on it's not
like you know this is this is going to
catch some eyes because it's this plum
with this kind of burnt gold
really nice i i'm blown away by this
style i mean that's just that's a great
fine teddy that's cool that's a winner
now this is my number one that's your
number one yeah yeah well you're talking
four times the price i got it but the
dial is you know i'm a doll that is
amazing that's cool okay now we're going
to jump back to the most affordable
watch on the table now this is a little
funky this is called the seagull 1963.
now this watch really the
thing behind this is if you're trying to
get into chronographs mechanical
chronographs you're spending four
figures at least it just is it's the
name of the game what if i told you this
watch is around 300 bucks it can't be
it is the move is made in china it is so
this is the backstory of this there was
a producer called venus the swiss brand
they sold off a lot of their technology
and their parts and their their actual
machining yeah to china and now there
are these and this was actually used by
you know military as well but
if you're trying to get into the world
of mechanicals and you're just trying to
see something i mean a column wheel
chronograph at 300
the most affordable swiss-made colony
that i'm aware of i think is with long
jean yeah
talking three four grand yeah so that's
the compelling thing about this now in
terms of you know what it's going for
compared to like a t-stone hamilton mass
market and very different but
but i mean that's a 300 watt that's
incredible does it actually function
here i'll show you let me wind it up
it's a manual wind and why that's i
think so awesome for a uh chronograph is
you can actually see
the mechanism work i mean you can see
the center wheel
you know think about that if it ever
breaks you might as well just throw it
out and get another one yeah that's
right these are kind of disposable when
you're talking because if you try to get
one of these service sherman a columnar
chronograph i mean forget it way more
expensive than this watch so just just
get another one but you know so it's
seen as a more of a disposable object um
but if you're just trying to have some
fun and to see i'm going to find this on
the wrist of a chinese military
yet back in the day yes you would
actually the movement feels it's pretty
snappy right yeah yeah yeah it's pretty
cool it's a very interesting dial too
this kind of pale green military kind of
vibe
great fine teddy very very very
interesting for 300 bucks i mean come on
you're just talking money there we're
just talking money three hundred dollars
for that you know you instead of going
out for dinner buy a watch
yeah you really could yeah you got you
got a budget for food but i mean that is
amazing that's amazing okay so now i
want to show a few different things here
one that i want to show is these are
kind of some fun dials let's do some fun
funky dials we'll show two of them now
one of them is zodiac now zodiac is a
brand new the brand yeah
1953 we know about the dive watches that
came out submariner blanc pond50 fathoms
that debate there's no debate over those
but what if i told you that there was
another dive watch that came out at that
same period the zodiac sea wolf doesn't
get much love now this is technically
more the aerospace gmt type of
architecture but zodiac they were
beloved by military personnel these are
available at px's during vietnam war and
they're really known for their you know
thousand two thousand dollar price range
they now have different ownership
they've kind of relaunched the brand but
just more eye-catching dialogue yeah
it's it's eye-catching it's
controversial too that that is not going
to please this is an acquired taste 100
i mean it's really funky chicken you got
this green thing going on
you know
i don't know i'm not loving it teddy
and two grand so what you're saying
seventeen
seventeen thousand seventeen hundred
seventeen hundred yeah okay sorry i need
to i need to specify for you i'm not
used to that
yeah it's it's it's also
you know i don't know i think
i don't know don't love it okay yeah
next one yeah this is a little bit funky
as well now this is a polarizing watch
no question about it these are known as
the cotton candy collection from aorus
bronze case
bronze case this is more of a unisex
watch
but this got people talking when we
started posting about these people were
like either i love these or
burn it with fire so i mean that was the
only way people had an opinion on these
yeah i think they're fun um when i wear
one it's it's a little bit tougher you
have to have a certain lifestyle and
circumstance but
the bronze case with those type of dials
there's also a pastelly green and a pink
but
what are your thoughts on that um so
bronze is interesting you're not going
to see a lot of that that's seeing it
more now it's definitely a bit trendy
what's the price point on this that's
2700 2700 on the bracelet yeah yeah i
mean like because you've got some really
interesting
that's patina so i do want to specify
when that comes straight out of the box
it's going to look a little bit
different but that's kind of the entry
with bronze right it gets you know shows
it's where so i actually like it because
it's it's a crazy chicken piece and in
every collection there should be even if
you only have a few watches you want
something really out there
just to start a conversation with this
is out there
first of all you know bronze plus this
this candy blue i mean it's really
really crazy and yellow
you know i like it i i think that's
interesting and you know
it's not my first go-to piece
but but you give that a thumbs up i'm
surprised well i think the dial is
really interesting i mean i like i
really appreciate a good dial that's not
anyways that's good that's you know i
think that's all right for what it is
okay so now i got some two different
approaches when it comes to watches one
of them is going to be material the
other one is going to be how they
display the time yeah
first is this rado so this
is a brand that is known mostly for
their use of material now they're known
for their use of ceramic now and as far
as i know from a full ceramic case and
bracelet this is one of the most
attainable ways you're going to get that
and there are masters of it they made
all of these
links from ceramic high-tech ceramic
lightweight
it's an interesting model as opposed to
spending a fortune with hublot you know
what you're saying yeah i mean any brand
honestly you're paying a big premium no
matter who the maker is in most cases
and they're one of the best at producing
it so they're just known for their
ceramics masters of that material price
point dealing with 3 800 bucks for that
one yeah for ceramic that's a heck of a
deal
um i like it i think it's you know it's
in the diver genre
uh and and you can add to your
collection with ceramic which costs a
fortune and so they've done a great job
bracelets
nice nothing wrong with it and the brand
is known i mean it's not it's not like
it's an unknown micro brand it's just
it's a well-known brand it's got some
heritage
yeah worldwide they're very well known
yeah us not as much but i mean they're
growing in terms of popularity so cool
brand i like how they mix a little bit
more of a vape
i give
if you don't have a dive watch and you
want to go right into something with
ceramic which is really cool this is it
very lightweight too yeah yeah that's so
beautiful it's beautiful now you might
be familiar with this just brand new
accutron you might have seen this in the
past so this is kind of a recreation of
their very iconic space view from a
modern perspective now this isn't going
to be mechanical but it's a pretty cool
watch now what you're seeing here and
you're seeing a lot of movement going on
here a lot of stuff very busy so this is
using electric static energy you have
two different generators here that are
providing power to this movement now
there's two different ways in which this
is actually driving us you have a motor
here that's visible and that's that
thing is just kind of spinning that's
driving that second hand there's another
one that is not visible that is also
going to drive your minute and your hour
hand yeah and it has three different
engines two different engines these are
your uh different uh generators that are
going to create that energy kind of work
like a you know traditional rotor on an
automatic watch and ultra precision on
this talking seconds a month in terms of
accuracy
and it's just cool it has a resting
position as well so after five minutes
we let this sit here it's going to go
into power save mode so five five
minutes second hand member's disposition
and the minute and the hour hand are
going to continue to tell the time for
10 days that's up to 10 days up to 10
days so
you know the elegant from fp jordan can
go for years remember the time that's
crazy but that's interesting it's pretty
cool yeah
so let's talk price
around 3 300 bucks 30 yeah i mean that
you know i think you're going to get a
lot of conversation of this piece i mean
all this crazy stuff going on
with the uh it's pretty fun i think it's
just a fun watch plus the green is
interesting yeah no i i get it that
would be a good buy there's no question
about it you're going to get a lot of
mileage with this
i mean it's people are going to look at
saying what is it how does it work i
mean you know you've got a that's a
great thing about a watch it starts a
conversation you never know where it's
going to go
and this is the kind of watch that would
do that
great good a good member of this
collection all right cool cool all right
let's look at a couple more look at a
couple watches from germany i have one
final watch on my wrist that you asked
about and i didn't want to tell you what
it's all about until this video so now
these are two watches from germany i
know we've had some discussion around
germany before in terms of their
production watches i think it presents
great value now nomos we've looked at in
the past i think in a previous video
this is called their autobahn they're a
little bit more germanic and minimalist
uh in terms of their approach they have
a lot of baja's influence yeah i see
that i see the the architectural
influence baja so i mean i get it what
um what is the price on this that is
going to be just south of four so so
it's getting up there it's getting up
there but flip that i mean flip that
watch around for
that's an in-house caliber proprietary
escapement they're making that all
in-house and that's i think i mean from
a finishing standpoint too very
beautiful for that price range if you
put that up against some other brands in
that price range i'm sorry yeah i i
think people are going to say what is
that i thought they're a little
minimalist on the on the on the um
you know the the bracelet or lack of um
this is a very very inexpensive band
this would look better uh probably with
with a good leather band frankly
um
you know yeah you're looking on that too
yeah
it's it's uh but but i like it i i i
think i think for four thousand dollars
it's not crazy um
it's certainly different than anything
else here
you went and grabbed for it right away
so that's i think very talented now that
is the glashutta original cq now where
these watches kind of span from is these
1950s 60s dive watches from germany yeah
kind of like a tutorial yeah it's got a
little bit of that um but really where
this one has become very popularized is
more in the larger case variant one
because that has a 30th that is a 39
millimeter but they also have a larger
one it's a pano date and it looks a bit
more germanic it also has an open case
back now this one does not which is the
biggest sin of this brand in this watch
because it is a beautifully finished
movement now i know so why did they why
did they do that
it's a dive watch most people think that
you shouldn't have a dive watch with an
open case back but i mean screw down
crown screw down crown suitable water
resistance ceramic bezel yeah i mean you
know i i mean
it's just another dive watch i mean it's
not it's okay it's not crazy it's
uh and what's the price 10 grand oh yeah
yeah it's not going to work yeah i think
you got a lot of optionality at ten
grand you do you do i mean the movement
is the number one selling point it's
such a shame that they didn't show it
because honestly it's jlc level in terms
of finishing i would probably go to
omega if i was gonna spend ten thousand
i might even go into rolex i mean it's
sort of uh
it's up there pretty watch but just the
the competition the price ranges i think
it's very tough i i don't see this as a
you know a go-to for ten thousand it's
just you can get into some major major
maison 10 000. you can okay but this
watch here yeah i want to show you this
watch you asked about it why i'm wearing
it so
this is a zenith l premiere i mean
really i thought it was a vintage rolex
xenothel premiere
so this watch in terms of what it
represents in 1969 the first integrated
automatic chronograph movement yeah and
probably the most underrated
i mean i would say movement of all time
the el primero yeah it's an icon
and this case is known as the a386 now
there's been some reissues and limited
editions that they've done in the past
but now they've brought this into
standardized that's a production watch
today this is a production watch finally
yes 8386 and very wearable 38
millimeters movements in terms of what
this was i mean this was inside the not
this particular one but the el premiere
was housed within the daytona for 12
years right so there's just a ton of
connection between this brand and i mean
yeah that's why i said it seemed to have
that rolex vibe to it right yeah i mean
if rolex is willing to put your movement
inside their watch what does that tell
you about you know what this is right so
it's cool 10th of a second central i
mean i think it's fun i mean it doesn't
have the most utility on a day-to-day
basis maybe not but it's cool to kind of
just see that flow
i just love the look on it there's i
must say it's got a beautiful look i
mean it is um that one's a bit more
muted there's also the traditional el
primero tri-color registers so those
three subdials will have um you know
different colors there which is kind of
more true to the dna it's a beautiful
piece it's 38 38 yeah so um
price point just over eight grand eight
grand well see that is a good use of
eight thousand dollars i mean you've got
the heritage of the movement
you've got the look and feel of a
classic uh rolex daytona with a vintage
vibe to it
great functionality on the you know
yeah
yeah yeah snappy look at that it's tenth
of a second kind of cool i mean you got
it you got a cenograph on so i mean you
know it's a little different there but
not many watches are you know had that
central screen
it's great
yeah no i think you know for the upper
priced offerings that you've tabled
today this is probably the best deal i
would think for the 8000 um you can't go
wrong with that it's going to look great
it's going to be very sporty it's also
going to look great with a suit on and
it's got a very interesting
dial
it's a winner and that's so if you're
going to spend 8 000 this is the one
right here no question all right so let
me go let me tell you so this is yeah
what are some stand outs here the
standouts on the top three i'm going
with um this is right so i'm going to do
you know
three stars yes i like it i like this
yeah
so number one um this piece is really
really something hamilton i love
hamilton is just um a standout at the
price you know hard to beat you start
talking about a collection and then
lastly on the hit parade here tough
there's a few that you probably could
put in here i know i know but i'm only
choosing three i'm doing three stars so
this plum is just too crazy i love it
too much
that
a great deal for the price also that's
under two grand yeah that is really so
that's a collection right there that is
a collection that's a collection right
you got everything here you got
everything that is really really
spectacular that's cool yeah well there
they are teddy it was fantastic thank
you you always bring in some you know
the great thing is you're digging and
finding all these micro brands and great
great value we've got to do this again
we've got to get another set and do it
again because i think what's terrific
about this is you're finding pieces for
people that want to go down the rabbit
hole but they don't want to spend a lot
of money so they want to get something
of great value all of these are great
value with the exception of this for 10
000 which i'm sorry
there's always one casualty isn't it
yeah exactly but teddy thanks that was
fantastic always a pleasure great well
we'll see you again soon don't forget to
click i want you to follow and just
hammer that like button all day long
take care